welcome in this video International
Master Rafael ma no name but I had this
guy right one out of two so could some
players here who have decent scores
against and we have a higher rating than
i am and i have at the moment so let's
try to get some points in now playing
this very solid line here against them
against this queens indian setup and
this is strange it's a very strange
moment to play this move now we have a
queen's gambit exchange with a misplaced
bishop won't be seven okay hmm attending
bishop a 6 which she implemented and
after this year so check with the Queen
I'm not sure about that but I'm going to
go for it an interesting way to play i
wonder if i should actually try to get
quick pressure on d5 here all right ok
let's this just develop it shouldn't be
bad really shouldn't be bad queen bee
three maybe what does he do then queen
be sick 26 so maybe this one if he
castles queen bee three no he didn't
okay I'll cancel no no before it's a
move not sure about it rupee one also is
a move trying to play a form what queen
bee three mark will be three is not not
really leading to much I guess before
after all
so it's not going to play c5 anytime
soon naughty for maybe so I'm going to
go here and put some pressure on the
five th eight okay
yeah I don't know what this move is
doing probably just nothing night you
form 94 I wanted to take now I cannot
take so I have to think about this do I
want to play prepare a 45 or not hmm
maybe even a four a five I have lots of
stuff on the queenside this is always
can can be tricky at times yep so I have
to edge I go here and try to stabilize
this
okay i still cannot take there because
of this discovery okay so Queen B 2 195
is an idea which she prevents see how UK
prevents it a little bit I still going
to play it I think this is a worthwhile
pawn sacrifice for the night coming to
deform he also threaten i def to so this
is this is definitely playable this one
sec the dark squared bishop is quite
quite important this piece yeah and I'm
going to put pressure now on the sea
pawn this is a move I overlooked I had
to take take their first okay
I did not think about this possibility
the night see night see for option this
makes a blacks position of course far
more I mean this is now ok fine i think
i was thinking i had good compensation
but 92 c4s changing thanks quite a lot
still cannot do this jan i can hardly
take him maybe I really have to regroup
to c5 at least keep them and keep this
attack them a 6 I mean snow is amazed
how quickly they can play these
positions but probably his right this
was probably a good decision check came
checking in rupee one probably a good
decision i'm really not sure so Bishop
f3 or where exactly will be eight it's
not leading to much
maybe all the way back I a celeb Bishop
c2 yeah I'm not sure about this position
I have rookie a day 6 is still weak time
morning maybe I'm not in such bad shape
here
gained quite some space yet maybe Bishop
f3 Bishop see sixes it's in the mix ok I
will take this now I guess 94 is coming
though ok let's cover let's cover this
let's cover this first kid here and soak
a 94 I'm going to cover check
ok I think this is just good for white
but 28 seconds this is the big problem
not easy also it's not easy to play
night before yeah I guess I'll trade
play a six
attending night 64
okay its approach just picking up this
pawns check no didn't see that one check
okay am i winning or not h5 I can take
right and they cover each other okay wow
so check check check check
black resigns ah well yeah I don't know
what it was very very tricky this
position I really overlooked this night
c4 possibility which here in this
position this is quite interesting here
I just have to I mean can I prevent it I
probably cannot right ah not really a I
mean this is a move that I don't want to
play i mean i can do that but it looks
it looks wrong yet to open up against f2
and so on I have this play against this
permit now that's never going to be an
advantage for me yeah 95 was an
interesting interesting way to play him
I mean I happy really played for this
idea starting from 92 and yeah but
ideally I did not see that you can go to
see for which is really really quite
annoying I mean I still have some
compensation yeah if you ask stop fish
it says equal but it's it's obviously
tricky to play i reroute the night and
so I'm not really sure if this is this
is such a great idea actually who'd like
check because I mean my pieces actually
get get more active than his and here g4
was good yeah I'm g4 is interesting you
just trying to gain space IAM this Nets
why the key advantage according to stock
fish
difficult and can I came I know look yet
i'm clearly better you with with with
her with what I played actually so it
wasn't terrible game I wasn't sure
during the game yeah I'm really clearly
clearly ahead check 93 is even stronger
and then just take the pawn okay but I
can you have to have to look at the time
situation it seems I never really
checked spoiled the the wind gently tlie
yeah this is a draw with before okay
yeah i already had the hunch that this
should be a draw I'm what I should have
done is check here to here I should go
to do this and then I can actually tell
him I'm not sure that this that is
progress to the draw but around here I
can of course play more precisely 95 as
a move yeah just not just not here
nights if I just winning and then take
here not stumbling into this fork but I
had no time I had no time it was
interesting right okay thanks for
watching